- I'm Ben.
- I'm Amanda.
- I'm Jen.
- I'm Chris.
- [Everyone] And I believe in ghosts.
- I have no real reason
for actually believing in ghosts.
I was raised Roman Catholic,
so maybe it's a religious thing.
- I believe that ghosts
could be out there.
I haven't seen them personally,
but I have definitely not counted them out
of the realm of possibility.
- I watched a lot of horror movies
and was really gung-ho
on ghost and spirit life.
- I'm friends with a
lot of spiritual people.
They told me that I have
an affinity for spirits,
and I'm hoping that that means
that I won't get possessed.
Yes.
- I have no idea what to expect tonight.
- [Ben] The closer we get to
actually having to go there,
the more I can feel my nerves
getting a little cranked up.
- [Chris] What I'm hoping will happen is
that there will probably be ghosts
that try to communicate with us,
but I don't think it's gonna be violent,
like in horror movies.
- [Amanda] The worst thing
that could happen tonight
is someone getting possessed.
- [Voiceover] Oh, (bleep).
- [Amanda] I am immediately
regretting everything right now.
- This seems like a stupid, (bleep) idea.
- My name is Chad. I'm co-founder
of Amadillo Paranormal.
- I'm Josh. I'm the founder.
- This is an asylum I had found before.
It's been kind of locally known.
- [Josh] There's no actual
evidence of this being an asylum
It's all folklore. There's no
actual address to this place.
There's no real roads here.
- [Chad] Literally in the middle
of nowhere. - [Josh] Yeah.
- [Chad] A couple things
that we've gotten here,
we've gotten a lot of voices.
Me and Daniel actually
heard a little boy laughing.
- [Josh] We've gotten
EMF hits here confirming
that there is some spirit
that either believes they're
a nurse or was once a nurse.
- [Chad] Let's go ahead and
get this started, you guys.
Everything off.
- [Voiceover] All lights.
- [Amanda] Oh, (bleep) me.
(rubs hands together)
- [Chad] Hey, is there
anybody here with us tonight?
You've seen us earlier.
We have a smaller group.
They actually believe in you.
Do you feel it? It's all cold.
So what it does is you'll hear this noise,
and it'll cycle to the radio stations.
We're out in the middle of nowhere.
There's no radio stations out here.
It's gonna be blank. If you hear a voice
or anything come through,
most likely it's paranormal.
(paranormal rapping)
- [Chad] Is there anybody here tonight?
Ah, did you see that?
So that wasn't us.
- [Josh] Are you speaking to
us from the back building?
(paranormal rapping)
- [Chad] What?
- [Chad] Are you allowed to
come over here to this building?
(paranormal rapping)
- [Josh] How many of you are there?
- [Chad] There's another voice.
- [Chris] I heard that.
- [Amanda] I hate this.
(giggles)
- [Chad] Are you guys ok?
- [Amanda] Yeah.
That is kind of eerie. Just like I said,
keep your eyes open everywhere.
And when you're ready,
everybody go ahead and go dark.
(paranormal rapping}
- [Amanda] Do you hear something?
- [Chris] Yeah, I hear something, too.
- [Voiceover] What? Behind you?
- [Chris] Yeah. It just
sounds like crackling
that's separate from that.
- [Amanda] Yeah. I'm not sure
if it's people moving around or something.
- [Chad] Ok. Well, I mean
there's nobody behind you, so.
- [Amanda] Oh, cool.
- [Chad] You're the last line of defense.
Are you still here with us?
(paranormal rapping)
- [Daniel] (mumbles)
something right out there.
- [Chad] What?
- [Ben] Something ran across out there.
- [Chad] Out where?
- [Daniel] Out in the distance,
where this building ends
- [Chad] (mumbles) behind us right now.
- [Daniel] Right there.
- [Amanda] I think we're good.
- [Chris] I think we're good.
- [Voiceover] We're good.
Ghost hunting was exhillerating.
I thought it was a lot of fun.
- I was disappointed.
- Not much happened as I expected it to,
but I still felt like
there was something there.
- Through the course of the night,
I felt like I went and faced this fear
that was probably rooted in a lot
of irrational, imagionary thinking.
- I was terrified the entire time.
I came out of it very nauseous, actually.
- I still believe that supernatural things
can occur out there.
- I definitely still
think that ghosts exist,
that paranormal activity
exists, places are haunted.
- I still believe that there are things
that we can't see that interact with us.
And there are people that say
that they want real,
concrete evidence for it,
but that's not how the spiritual
world is supposed to work.
- Just because you didn't see anything,
doesn't mean that there
wasn't anything there.
- I ain't afraid of no
(loud shrieking)
- [Chad] Keep your mind
open. Keep your ears open.
Sometimes you'll feel a
slight touch, a breath.
- [Bearded Man] Is it just
me, or does everyone now feel
like they're feeling breaths and touches?
- It's just so sad
what's happening over there.
- Oh, yeah.
You don't know the half of it.
(elevator music)